you who
I got an idea feel free to say no but
can we switch seats I will not take no
for an answer
why that's the combat seat Jonathan
Livingston Seagull
if you gonna be in the combat seat then
you got to be willing to blast up on
some carries
because of great power comes great
response a trilograms
good morning ladies and gentlemen we are
about to begin boarding South Northern
Airlines flight 34 to Grand Rapids
an important group one excuse me I'm in
boarding group one
and we would like to begin pre-boarding
with our first class passengers
first-class passengers only please
next are business class passengers may
now board
okay now we would like to welcome our
Regal Alliance Elite members Regal
Alliance Elite members
okay now all passengers with children
anyone with small children you mean
bored now
okay we would like to continue boarding
with uniformed military personnel what
why kids this is
thank you for service thank you so much
for your service God bless you thank you
for your service thank you for your
service
all right people in wheelchairs
any priests nuns rabbis imans what why
do they get special treatment assalamu
alaikum I've never
that's typical any old people in
wheelchairs with babies
any old religious people with military
babies what's a military
thank you for your service
Jason Schwartzman
anyone with a blue suitcase you may now
board finally no not you sir not me this
is a blue suitcase that's a blue
computer bag so you're not you're not
gonna let me on then
yeah
damn it damn it damn it damn it God damn
it
anyone who doesn't seem cranky
drunk people who will now be boarding
any drunk people
all right nope it's my bag sir
oh
hello
oh hey Christian
yeah
totally
well you have your favorites and I have
my favorites
okay
call you later
cow cow
boarding group one
[Music]
[Applause]
I got him
everyone
[Music]
we've got Jason's Fortune to let you
wrap it up people
morning room one over here
get a boarding group one ah
that's it and he talks too much that's
why I like you you're not talking just
listening it's good
and the captain has turned on The Fast
and seat belt sign a couple of
turbulence coming up should be no
problem just remain in your seat until
the sign is turned off thank you for
your cooperation
okay
excuse me I'm gonna go to the bathroom
hi excuse me yeah yeah I need you to
take your seat the fast and seat belt
sign is on yeah I'm just gonna go to the
bathroom for a second I'll be right back
okay I understand what you want to do
unfortunately I'm gonna need you to
observe the fast and seatbelt cyan
that'd be much appreciated
right just I read on the internet that
it's not against the law for me to go to
the bathroom while the fast and seat
belt sign is on so
but is it against the law though
the light is on
against the law
you see that there's a picture of a seat
belt on this no but is it against the
law
the fast and seat belt line is on but is
it against her see about science but is
it against the seatbelt sign is on but
is it against the email sign but is it
against the lights on Amazon
difficult you're being very difficult
not illegal not illegal not illegal okay
illegal illegal
[Music]
sir I have to piss and I have to in the
toilet can you lower your voice I have
to
lower your intensity you're louder than
me you're yelling you're in my face
sorry you're the one who I think needs
to tone it down but now you are
screaming at me you're hurting
that wasn't a word you're not saying a
word this is a word
that's not that's not a word that's a
tongue trick
okay sir sir if you would like I would
not like to
I would not like to sit down what I'd
like to do
is go take the bathroom
because
it's not a against
the law
so I'm gonna go to the bathroom
okay
mark
with a k
foreign
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
seat belt sign feel free to move around
the cabin
thank you for your cooperation
me oh excuse me sir are you sitting in
26g yes have I done something wrong no
no no we just wanted to ask if you would
mind switching seats so that a mother
and a child could sit together but
I'm back there right yeah but you'd
actually be sitting here
which is an economy Plus
um It's actually an upgrade
upgrade you say
economy Plus
yes sir oh
don't mind if we do great great uh carry
on
carry on yourself Alex
thank you
[Music]
economy Plus
for the Discerning passengers
we're not in Kansas anymore
we're leaving Topeka in the next 10
minutes I stand corrected looks like
we're gonna have a smooth flight trust
me I know the captain and he's one
smooth guy
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
of course he knows the captain
he is the captain Oh Oh
move over Colin mockery there's a new
face in the biz
his name is Captain oh
have to be an economy plus to get it I
guess ah
extra foot room
one inch at least
[Music]
Sky shop magazine
oh the dog ears from my convenience
Lord of the Rings cups
Lord of the Rings tables
holy shotsu massage
economy plus it hurts a little bit but I
like it
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
all right
yo
hey y'all
on y'all
Excuse excuse me
oh man oh man oh man
I tell you one thing if 9 11's were to
happen up on this airplane
don't worry we got this
okay I have no idea what you're talking
about
he's sad and that fdm Terry's is going
to try something up in here today like
the bounce Boogie and bump
that we got dead
sir do you mean terrorists oh yeah hell
yeah baby you ain't talking about Terry
God and I certainly ain't talking about
no terry cloth
I mean it but Terry up on this plane he
was thinking about trying to do
something we're gonna wax him up you're
gonna you're gonna what we're gonna Drax
at him
Scouts
I think when my partner's trying to say
if any terries come up in here we gonna
get our Bergeron
did something happen or did I
missed something that's hypothetical or
oh we're gonna definitely Drive some
hypotheticals on that Terry's clavicle
because I'm talking about
squeeze squeeze squeeze
you just wish so don't you just wish in
your heart a heart thumb Terry would
come up in here trying some grab ass and
the touchy feeling that's the opposite
of what I want to have happen on a plane
okay that's unfortunate conference
this was unexpected it certainly was I'm
thrown right now as to who's gonna be
our comrade you can still hear you he
doesn't have the heart not a gumption it
literally right next to me oh three
break three
you who
I got an idea feel free to say no but
can we switch seats I will not take no
for an answer
why that's the combat seat Jonathan
Livingston Seagull
if you gonna be in the combat seat then
you got to be willing to blast up on
some carries
because of great power comes great
response of trilograms
okay I just I just wanted some leg room
um okay Max legroom you get yours
meanwhile I'm gonna go hating pant in
the Airy awesome Terrys especially when
they get froggy
ribbit ribbit
um you gonna have to be ready to kidnap
a Terry I don't you're gonna have to be
ready to touch you I care I don't think
that's necessary absolutely you have to
fire board those mother gems I don't
even understand what that means do you
trust me no
I'll take that as a yeah okay
okay
draft
these terries come up in here trying to
act froggy then we gonna give them the
Rainbow Connection but
oh you best believe it baby we gonna be
eating like Diane Keaton
2.350 inches baby chef wax
perfectly League whale and if those
don't work
you know I'm working up that plan leave
brother
3D printer baby 100
polyurethane they can't detect these
commandment generals
that's that's what the devil weapons
where you at Tammy relax
[Applause]
oh my gosh
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
tracks
I know
Scouts
[Music]
[Music]